voilà monsieur bonsoir voici les titres
de l'actualité de ce mardi 22 août le
président poutine arrive enfin mourmansk
déclare une journée de deuil national
certaines familles refusent de
participer à la cérémonie officielle
jean pierre chevènement qualifie d'
insensés les propos de françois santoni
qu menaçant de venger lui même la mort
de son ami rossi la compagnie d'aviation
à om se fait sévèrement rappelé à
l'ordre par l'aviation civile trop
d'incidents techniques sur les avions
trop de retards dans les vols
un centre de vacances pour handicapés
fermer les 35 pensionnaires vivaient
dans des conditions d'hygiène du
surveillance totalement insuffisantes
un président pour cinq ans à france
télévisions dans ce journal marc tessier
nous dira à ses projets pour le nouveau
groupe qui intègre désormais la
cinquième
tout va bien pour moi je viens de
recevoir mon brevet de sous-mariniers
c'est la dernière lettre écrite le 23
juillet par sergei vie tchenko à sa mère
il avait à peine 20 ans il était
cuisinier dans le koursk et ce message
posthume publiés dans la presse
aujourd'hui bouleverse plus que tout
autre témoignage l'opinion publique
bernard lebras quelque part dans un
pauvre russe de la mer arctique dimanche
23 juillet 2000 firmament tout va bien
pour moi je travaille comme cuisinier
viens de recevoir mon brevet nous étions
en mer et maintenant nous sommes au port
en train d'embarquer des missiles quand
nous aurons fini nous repartirons en
aires puis rentreront à la base de
severomorsk pour le défilé militaire
ils ont finalement accepté que ton fils
sergei travail aux messes du bateau et
donc je ne travaille plus dans la soute
j'ai de la chance je suis autorisé à me
laver tous les jours et à dormir 12h par
mais alors maman valentina tu peux
vraiment conduire une voiture pour être
honnête maintenant je ne peux imaginer
au volant j'ai hâte que tu m'envoies une
photo de toi au volant
moi j'ai reçu mon brevet de
sous-mariniers nous nous trouvions par
environ 100 mètres sous l'eau mais c'est
loin d'être le plus profond que notre
bâtiment peut descendre
480 m n'est pas un problème pour le
koursk pour fêter ce brevet nous avons
été appelés sur la passerelle nous avons
tous bu une tasse d'eau de mer et
embrasser un marteau plein de graisse
puis nous avons reçu un certificat et le
commandant a serré la main à tout le
monde mais après avoir bu l'eau de mer
où nous sommes tous ont bien peu matin
au revoir maman valentine je t'aime tu
me manques et crimes signé sergei
vincenzo 20 ans sous marine à bord du
koursk
à normand ce que les familles des 118
marins disparus laissent éclater leur
chagrin leur désespoir plusieurs de ces
familles refusent de participer à la
cérémonie officielle prévue demain à
laquelle doit assister vladimir poutine
et pour la première fois ces mères parle
gilles rabin les a rencontrés regardez
son document elles sont partis ce matin
de la base secrète de vie diaye vont
elles ont fait le voyage à mourmansk
pour parler à la presse qui est
interdite là bas elles sont jeunes elles
sont vaines toute femme d'officiers du
sous marin naufragé elles sont
désespérés et on leur attendant tickets
ne savent plus que croire
nous sommes choqués à ce que nous avons
appris les travaux de sauvetage sont
arrêtés nous on continue de croire et
d'avoir de l'espoir que nos maris sont
vivants
c'est trop simple d'annoncer le 2 pour
tout le pays mais c'est les drapeaux et
le lendemain vivant comme si rien ne
s'était passé
on aurait dit une vérité terrible pour
les ressortir à de l'eau seulement dans
un an on ne mettra pas le foulard de
deuil tant qu'on aura pas vu les corps
jusqu'à mardi les marrant taper sur la
coque à coups de marteau il demandait et
des lignes dans notre continent il y à
de l'eau qui arrive
on ne savait pas que le sous-marin
commencé à être inondées on s'adresse à
vous sos sauver nos maris nous en
appelons au monde entier à clinton à
l'amérique et à tous les autres
l'allemagne sauvé nos hommes
musique mélangeant norvégien sur de
travailler parce qu'on les paie pas
assez peut-être des compagnies des
grands hommes à des mécènes pourrait
donner de l'argent pour que les
sauvetages continue
si le sauvetage avaient commencé dès le
début avec l'aide de tous les étrangers
nos maris serait déjà à la maison
déguisez vous tous
prenez soin les uns des autres soyez
plus attentif aux autres aimez-vous et
protégez vous les uns les autres
toujours parce qu'après je vous allez
regretter
même s'il n'y a qu'un seul survivant il
pourra dire la vérité pourquoi c'est
arrivé c'est le silence total sur la
vague du sous marin
ces criminels sans meurtre
aujourd'hui c'était le 11e jour après le
naufrage
alors que le pays tout entier porte le
deuil des 118 marins du koursk beaucoup
de russes sont persuadés que tout n'a
pas été fait pour sauver les hommes
alors qu'au moins de deux jours les
norvégiens ont pu pénétrer dans le sens
marin on ne comprend toujours pas
pourquoi il a fallu tant de jours aux
responsables pour demander des secours
explications et commentaires claude 100
perd
une minute de silence et un simple
bouquet de fleurs jetés à la mer
les secours anglais et norvégiens ont
quitté ce matin la zone du drame
hier soir en direct à la télévision
le commandant en chef de la flotte du
nord l'amiral popov a tenu à s'adresser
en personne aux familles des victimes
en quatre minutes il rend hommage à ses
118 marins disparus
je me battrai toute ma vie dit il or
regarder droit dans les yeux l'homme
responsable de cette tragédie l'allusion
vise directement le président coustilles
soleil
pour finir l'amiral s'adresse aux
familles
pardonnez moi pardonnez moi de ne pas
avoir sauvé dollars
en fin d'après midi le président poutine
est arrivé à severomorsk base de la
flotte du nord aux premiers rangs pour
l'accueillir l'amiral popov le regard en
dit long
ils ne changeront pas un mot
que s'est il passé à bord du court ce
pourquoi les autorités ont-elles garder
si longtemps le silence
y at il eu une explosion à bord dans le
compartiment torpille
le sous-marin at-il heurté un bâtiment
surface
at il été touché par un autre sous-marin
aujourd'hui on parle d'une quatrième
hypothèse le koursk aurait pu être
atteint par une torpille ou par un
missile lancé par un autre bâtiment rue
au moment du drame il y avait des
manoeuvres militaires en surface avec
près de 30 navires il ya peut être eu
une bavure un accident que les russes
auraient voulu dissimuler les enquêtes
seront secrets et les enquêteurs ne
seront pas indépendant du commandement
militaire
sur la télévision russe on peut voir en
permanence d hommage aux marins décédés
aujourd'hui le pouvoir semble pressé de
tourner la page n'est pas le peuple
russe
sur les écrans des filets non des 118
disparu
118 nom que le pouvoir aura bien du mal
à faire oublier
et nous retrouvons à mourmansk gilles
rabin gillon de la dîmière poutine vient
enfin voir les familles après avoir
beaucoup hésité manifestement est plutôt
loin des caméras
oui vous savez françoise l'une des
femmes que vous avez entendu d'une des
femmes d'officiers vous avez entendu
dans le document que nous avons envoyé
disait poutine je voudrais pouvoir le
briser en morceaux une autre a ajouté
poutine vient avec le patriarche
orthodoxe parce qu'il a peur poutine
c'est que personne jamais en russie ne
lèvera la main sur le patriarche alors
il veut se cacher derrière ce que chris
et femmes c'est ce qui se crée un peu
partout en russie tout un peuple dit à
haute voix qu'il en a assez des méthodes
de ses dirigeants souvent incompétents
toujours irresponsables qui prennent des
décisions incohérentes et
contradictoires et qui jamais n'assume
les conséquences de leurs actes merci
gilles rabin on ne sait pas encore si le
sous marin nucléaire restera au fond de
la mer de barents ce qui implique que
l'on ne pourrait pas enterrer les morts
comme le recommande la religion
orthodoxe ou au contraire si le sous
marin pour être renfloué des techniques
existent levé le bâtiment avec une grue
ou remplir des relais ballast pour cela
il faut faire appel à la technologie
étrangère au delà du coût financier les
russes pourrait hésiter à renflouer le
bateau pour des raisons stratégiques
explications eric lemasson
à l'échelle d'un bâtiment de pareilles
taille il ne s'agit pas d'un échouage en
eau profonde le koursk était
probablement en immersion périscopique
c'est à dire presque en surface lorsque
l'avarié survenue à présent il gît par
108 mètres de fond c'est peu c'est moins
que sa propre longueur
seulement puisqu'aucune marine de guerre
au monde ne maîtrise la technique le
renflouement des pav doit être sous
traitée à quelques rares sociétés
occidentales les précisions techniques
donnés par les français de la comex ont
de quoi surprendre non nous dit-on il
n'est pas difficile de faire remonter à
la surface les dix-huit mille tonnes du
koursk un sous marin normalement sa
flotte la position sous marine est
anormal un sous marin comme le koursk
qui pèse 18 mille tonnes dans l'air sous
l'eau il ne pèse rien par la poussée
d'archimède or tout le monde sait que
lorsqu'un sous marins restent sur le
fond et qu'il ne peut pas remonter c'est
qu'il est forcément plein d'eau remplir
des relais ballast est donc l'une des
méthodes envisageables les voies d'eau
serait au préalable boucher puis une
injection d'air comprimé viderait
totalement le koursk de son dos l'autre
technique et le levage deux barges avait
cru embarqué pourrait suffire les sortes
de la sogea en acier serait alors placés
à chaque extrémité de l'épave certaines
rues peuvent lever chacune dix mille
tonnes en fait les véritables obstacles
au renflouement du koursk sont d'ordre
financier
pareille opération coûterait une fortune
à la russie et surtout d'ordre militaire
tous les services de renseignement
militaires occidentaux ont dans leurs
bureaux des spécialistes dont le métier
consiste grâce à des petits détails à
recomposer des ensembles technologiques
très complexe en général ni travail à
partir de petits fragments de détails
parfois des photographies en trois fois
rien matricule 441 le koursk était le
plus récent des sous marins de la classe
oscar 2 lancé en 1994 dernier né de la
série ils bénéficiaient des derniers
perfectionnements russe en matière de
sonars propulsion nucléaire et surtout
armements il y a trente ans de sous
marins français disparaît c'est en mer
en 1968 la minerve ou couleur aux
éditeurs années avec à son bord 53
hommes d'équipage en 1970 disparaissait
à son tour à l'époque l'armée française
n'avait guère et l occase sur les
circonstances exactes de l'accident et
les corps des marins péris en mer sont
restés à bord des submersibles
aujourd'hui on commence à comprendre un
peu mieux ce qui s'est passé même si le
secret défense n'est pas totalement levé
en guérit michaël darmon et christophe
la roque à ce jour là le port de toulon
se réveille sous alerte générale les
navires de guerre envahissent la mer des
hélicoptères survolent la méditerranée
ce 27 janvier 1968 un sous marin
français vient de couler au large de
toulon la minerve a disparu avec
cinquante trois hommes à bord la
mobilisation est immédiat
préliminaire
c'est pas possible mère en pleurs c'est
pas possible il est peut-être pas là où
les jeux parus même à le retrouver
pendant trois jours il va espérer
espérer revoir ce jeune frère le second
maître de la minerve celui là même qui a
lancé le dernier appel radio l'espoir
est permis dans les recherches sont
intenses
la jeune femme armani
et chopard est de tous les côtés des
hackers de guerre
costaud
elle est une auberge en jarez
donc on a eu l'impression qu'ils avaient
car même le mystère qui fallait qu'ils
élucident rapidement
devenu le sheed pas et le mystère ne
sera jamais élucidé l'épave jamais
retrouvé les rapports d'enquêté sont
classés confidentiel défense le général
de gaulle rendra hommage à l'équipage
des mousses sur l'héroïsme des hommes
rien sur les causes du naufrage l'époque
n'est pas à la polémique quand deux ans
plus tard un deuxième sous-marin
français le riz 10 sombre à son tour
l'armée de nouveau se tait les
sous-marins français ont-ils été
victimes d'avariés techniques et est il
fiable
nul doute que ces interrogations devait
rester sans réponse à une époque où la
france vend d'être encore ces sous
marins aux marines étrangères
le ministre de l'intérieur jean pierre
chevènement qui participé aujourd'hui
aux cérémonies de la libération de paris
a évoqué la situation en corse et l'a
qualifié d' insensé les propos tenus par
françois santoni menaçant de venger la
mort de son ami jean michel rossi
reportage armes au goûter et aurélie
legrand
jean pierre chevènement s'était donné
trois semaines de vacances de silence et
de réflexion
ce matin en marge de la commémoration de
la libération de paris le ministre de
l'intérieur a rappelé que sur le dossier
corse il n'a pas changé il refuse
toujours de défendre le projet de loi
sur le nouveau statut de l'île alors
question restera-t-il oui ou non au
gouvernement en guise de réponse le
ministre préfère sourire quelle est
votre implication personnelle alors moi
la création personnelle vous la dirai
pas
au mois de juillet jean pierre
chevènement critiqué le plan jospin pour
la corse les attentats du mois d'août et
l'assassinât de l'ancien nationaliste
jean michel rossi confirme selon lui
toutes ces craintes après les menaces de
françois santoni de venger son ami jean
michel rossi jean pierre chevènement
demande au frère ennemi du nationalisme
armata corsa et le flnc de déposer les
armes
considère que toutes les organisations
dites nationalistes ce jce l'armata
corsa ou des organisations regroupées
autour du fnc doivent rompre avec la
violence
s'engager explicitement à ne plus
utiliser l'action armée clandestine
c'est de cette seule condition est
moralement que à un processus
démocratique peut se développer dans un
récent sondage 55% des français
interrogés souhaitent que jean pierre
chevènement reste au gouvernement
l'intéressé lui donnera sa réponse en
fin de semaine il a rendez vous avec le
nez jospin
dominique voynet satisfait de sa
participation gouvernementale est
confiant dans l'avenir des verts c'est
ce qu'elle a déclaré aujourd'hui à
l'université d'été de son mouvement en
ardèche malgré les critiques assez
directe de noël mamère et guy hascoët
qu'ils veulent lancer le débat interne
et pendant que dehors quelques centaines
de chasseurs tenté en vain de perturber
la réunion reportage philippe oissery et
vincent ferreira
il voulait crier leur colère à dominique
voynet aux verts ils n'ont pu que
pousser la chansonnette aux gardes
mobiles au tableau de chasse de ces
quelque 200 chasseurs une université
d'été transformée en camp retranché et
une plaine besace de rancoeur
à l'intérieur en revanche on parle
beaucoup partout noël mamère et guy
hascoët venus avec leurs contributions
sur la place des verts dans la majorité
plurielle tente de nouer des alliances
sur l'air de nous c'est nous et il faut
que le parti évolue il faut que le parti
se renforce son autonomie oui il faut
qu'ils abandonnent la ligne du compromis
pour choisir la ligne de l'autonomie
contractuelle plus question donc comme
ils l'écrivent dans leur texte de
déclaration radical le week end devant
les militants et des discours lénifiants
le lundi pour rassurer le premier
ministre de toute évidence dominique
voynet a lu le texte je ne résiste pas à
la tentation de dire on n'est pas ici
dans le discours habituel du week end
d'août il faudrait demander par de la
vie hein on est on est bon on est dans
ce qui fait la difficulté des
responsables vaise
assurer la visibilité des objectifs de
long terme et la lisibilité des étapes
par lesquelles on y parvient les
militants plutôt fier qu'il y ait débat
dans leurs parties n'en sont pas moins
partagée
dominique one il a fait comme elle ni ce
qu'elle a pu mais moi je dis qu'elles
ont prouvé beaucoup mieux le boulot
qu'elle a fait depuis trois ans il est
il est intéressant est que
la poser des jalons qui pour continuer à
creuser
moi je la soutiens le congrès de
toulouse en novembre prochain
s'annoncent d'ores et déjà mouvementée
en attendant dominique bonnet ne veut
montrer qu une chose sa sérénité
la compagnie a au m dont les avions
connaissent pannes retards annulations
en tout genre s'est fait rappeler à
l'ordre par l'aviation civile qui
s'inquiète des incidents répétés
notamment sur les dc 10 de la compagnie
le patron du club med l'ue juge lui
aussi intolérable les retards qui
pénalise les vacanciers explications
david boeri
trois heures de retard cet après midi
pour le vol à waimes à destination de
fort-de-france les passagers prennent
leur mal en patience certains se
permettent même une pointe d'humour
comme des cons on avait le choix entre
air france et à wayne nom nadir france
vient souvent en grève dont comprend web
et le problème c'est que c'est pas la
grève si leurs traces mais les retards
ne font pas sourire tout le monde en un
mois le club méditerranée a recensé 21
vols à om avec plus de trois heures
trente de retard le week-end dernier 160
clients du club ont même passé 24 heures
à roissy trop c'est trop philippe
bourguignon le pdg du club med s'est
plaint directement la compagnie dans une
lettre il dénonce cette situation
devenue intolérable et envisage des
poursuites judiciaires plus grave encore
le 11 août dernier la direction générale
de l'aviation civile envoie un rappel à
l'ordre à aol elle parle de
dysfonctionnements importants dans la
maintenance de ses dc10 avant de
conclure ces événements sont de nature à
mettre en cause le contenu voire le
maintien de votre certificat de
transporteur aérien en clair la
compagnie risque de perdre toute
autorisation de vol depuis un ulm s'est
engagé à renforcer ses contrôles
techniques ce matin tentative
d'explication devant la presse avec le
discours plutôt embarrassé du directeur
technique suite à ces événements
excusons et c'est finalement le patron
d'un om qui donne la version officielle
je tiens très clairement pas sûr ici que
tout ceci se fait dans un pur respect de
la sécurité de nos vols les syndicats
eux mettent en cause la fusion en cours
avec r liberté r littoral piloté par
swissair
je pense qu'ils se sont attaché à
restructurer l'entreprise ils ont
peut-être perdu de vue le terrain et
l'exploitation en elle même pour faire
face à la crise à wayne vient de louer
un airbus a340 mais une autre zone de
turbulences est déjà en vue un préavis
de grève des salariés dimanche prochain
l'excédent commercial français a été
sérieusement entamée par le prix du
pétrole il a à peine dépassé les 30
milliards de francs sur les six premiers
mois de l'année alors que les
exportations notamment industrielle
reste un très très bon niveau la flambée
du prix du carburant a coûté 40
milliards de francs supplémentaires au
premier semestre 2000 la fin d'un empire
que l'on croyait prospère le groupe
bourgois numéro deux européen du poulet
a été mis aujourd'hui en dépôt de bilan
par le tribunal de sens la fin de
l'aventuré aussi pour un patron à la
forte personnalité
gérard bourgoin qui avait laissé la
gestion de son groupe à sa fille s'était
orientée vers le football histoire et
portraits avec nathalie moison olivier
sioux et gabriel camilla
c'est la plus grosse faillite ne
l'industrie agroalimentaire française la
chute d'un groupe devenu en quelques
années numéro deux européen de la
volaille à guerlesquin en bretagne ce
soir le délégué syndical venu aux
nouvelles espère que son usine toute
neuve sera bientôt racheter des
repreneurs qui doivent êtres qui doit se
manifester pour le 28 août et on espère
que nous septembre la situation sera
plus claire pour tout le groupe
en espérant que j ai pas de problème de
niveau salariés un dépôt de bilan
logique après celui en mars de la
principale filiale du groupe bourgeois à
l'époque face aux caméras font fondateur
un homme qui parle de lui à la troisième
personne tenait à rassurer tous les
problèmes vont être réglés au cas par
cas mais pour ceux qui pensaient que le
navire bourgoin on aurait pas de
capitaine tu veux dire qu'il a non
seulement le président en titre pour une
bourgogne qui l'a également de président
du groupe gay la rl je renvoie une
sérénité démenti dans les mois qui
suivent avec les faillites en cascade de
nombreux élevages bretons crise de la
dioxine chute des aides européennes à
l'exportation
les ennuis du groupe bourgoin sont aussi
le résultat d'investissements hasardeux
une course au gigantisme soutenu par le
crédit lyonnais qui a permis au groupe
d'accumuler les est souvent comparé à
bernard sa fille gérard bourgoin ami de
fidel castro s'illustre sur l'échiquier
politique français à droite en 95 il se
félicite de l'élection de jacques chirac
les mesures du projet chirac ont été
aujourd'hui entérinée par un maximum de
français et puis et même à droite de la
droite puisqu'il fut président du centre
national des indépendants et des paysans
pilote de rallye et passionné de sport
il est depuis juin président de la ligue
nationale de football ce soir gérard
bourgoin se refuse à tout commentaire
sur l'avenir du groupe pour lui cette
page est tournée
deux nouveaux cas de vache folle ont été
détectés dans le finistère et dans
l'orne l'animal du finistère appartenait
à un troupeau de 180 têtes celui de
l'orne d'un troupeau de 124 bovins tous
les animaux ont déjà été abattus un
corps de vacances qui accueillait 35
handicapés mentaux a été fermée hier par
la préfecture du gard ce camp qui
n'était pas agréé pour recevoir des
personnes dépendantes présentait des
conditions sanitaires déplorables six
moniteurs sans aucune qualification
s'occuper des 35 résidents ils ont été
rapatriés sur d'autres camps reportage
veronica guillaume et denis par dano
officiellement c'était un gîte d'étape
comme un autre dans les faits chaque été
et même parfois à pâques depuis
plusieurs années champclauson accueillir
des adultes handicapés dans des
conditions que certains voisins qualifié
aujourd'hui d' un peu juste et qui vous
paraissez c'est juste que ça
le voyez comment vous donne induite le
matelas qui sortait un but depuis
la semaine dernière une handicapée est
décédé peut-être sans aucun lien avec
les conditions d'accueil toujours est il
qu'une jeune animatrice chargée de
distribuer les médicaments sans en avoir
les compétences a alors tout dit à la
gendarmerie le constat effectué est
accablant trente cinq handicapés dont 12
lourd confié à seulement six moniteurs
sans qualification dans des conditions
déplorables
des couches qui inclurait chez le sol
qui était sur les matelas les matelas
était un bon créé un très abîmé
on a eu assez peur au niveau des
médicaments puisqu'ils étaient stockés
dans des poches plastiques dans une
pièce
normalement dévolus à la chaufferie
l'association vacances comme tous elle
plaide l'ignorance
j'ai été très surpris quand la
commission de sécurité m'a sorti une
norme qui concerne et elle saute nous on
a toujours fonctionné exempt du cap est
sur place on n'a jamais caché qu'on
était handicapée et personnels d'une
voie en disant voilà les groupes que
vous accueillez nécessite tel ou tel
aménagement particulier selon la
préfecture les handicaps étaient trop
lourds pour que l'association se
permettent de telles approximations
d'autant que chaque pensionnaire avait
réglé 8000 francs un mois de vacances au
centre
un violent orage de grêle a causé
d'importants dégâts dans le nord de
l'aveyron près de laguiole une trentaine
de pompiers et même un chasse-neige ont
dû intervenir pour dégager les gréements
qui ont causé beaucoup de dégâts
certains grêlons vous le voyez atteignez
plus de 8 cm de diamètre
l'activité orageuse est très importante
en ce moment en france hier un enfant a
été tué à thonon les bains avant-hier en
jeune homme à paris a été foudroyé il
est évidemment très difficile de prévoir
où la foudre va tomber en cas d'orage et
parfois les paratonnerres ne suffisent
pas à s'en protéger reportage hélène
verne et didier rocker
le territoire français traversé ces
derniers jours par une série d'orages
hier en l'espace de 24 heures météo
france a recensé plus de 13000 impacts
de foudre pas plus ni moins que
d'habitude chaque année la foudre frappe
en millions de fois 40 journées d'orage
en moyenne qui génère de multiples
impacts
imprévisible meurtrière la foudre tue 10
à 20 personnes par an
il n'est pas possible de dire où la
foudre va tomber on sait prévoir ou vont
passer un orage ou va arriver à un orage
toutefois les endroits susceptibles
d'être foudroyé c'est plutôt les
endroits où il ya des pics métalliques
des endroits où vous et des
paratonnerres ses partenaires qui ont
été touchés les endroits montagneux sont
en général les plus foudroyé dans ce
laboratoire edf est parvenu à recréer le
phénomène naturel pour mieux le
comprendre et mieux s'en protéger
principal outil le paratonnerre qui agit
comme un aimant il ne réduit pas
l'impact de la foudre mais permet de la
canaliser a la particularité de
paratonnerre c'est de pouvoir
effectivement d'en capturer la foudre
plus haut et plus vite que n'importe
quel autre point existants et ce qui lui
confère donc un grand rayon de
protection puisque plus le captur la
foudre aux puces il couvre une zone donc
étendu en france seuls les sites dits
sensibles zone pétrochimique silo
doivent s'équiper d'un système de
protection mais il n'existe aucune
obligation légale pour les bâtiments
recevant du public encore moins pour les
particuliers pourtant les dégâts
occasionnés par la foudre ne sont pas
négligeables leur coût a été évalué à 20
francs par an et par habitant
plus de quatre ans après l'explosion du
vol 800 de la twh au large de new york
quelques minutes après le décollage vers
paris les autorités américaines ont
conclu cet après midi à la thèse de
l'accident mettant ainsi un point final
à lenquête ce qui est loin de satisfaire
les familles de victimes reportage
etienne leenhardt et art au diamant
michel breistroff et josé crémadès se
sont retrouvés ce matin comme chaque
fois qu'une étape est franchie dans l'
enquête sur le crash de la
twofour54 de l'ong island où il ya
quatre ans les familles des 230 victimes
étaient venus se recueillir michel
breistroff qui a perdu son fils dans
l'accident cherche toujours à comprendre
aucun problème j'aurai fini de faire des
cauchemars bien que avec ce qui s'est
passé à concorde depuis un mois je fais
des cauchemars
après quatre ans d enquête et un boeing
reconstituer presque à 100% dans ce
hangar les enquêteurs ont conclu à
l'explosion du réservoir central de
l'appareil problème rien ne permet
encore aujourd'hui de dire ce qui a
provoqué cette explosion une défaillance
du système électrique peut-être mais
face à l'inconnu les hypothèses les plus
folles circulent on a parlé d'une bombe
d'un missile tiré d'un bateau ce matin
encore des témoins du drame étaient
venus dire leur certitude d'avoir vu un
très lumineux dans le ciel juste avant
l'explosion pour raisons de sécurité on
les a fait sortir les enquêteurs pensent
que ce trait lumineux était en fait
l'appareil ans il vient l'été au moins
mais on a expliqué le
ce que les témoins français avoir vu et
juste oui combien ils sont autant qu'il
n'y a pas de musique les enquêteurs ont
rappelé ce matin aux familles qu'ils
n'ont pas trouvé le début d'un indice
permettant de conclure à un acte
criminel et que les accusations selon
lesquelles l'on chercherait à étouffer
une autre vérité sont un mauvais service
rendu aux victimes aux familles qui
cherchent les certitudes les autorités
américaines n'ont donc que des réponses
partielles à apporter il est probable
que l'on ne connaîtra jamais la cause
exacte de l'explosion du réservoir
central de ce boeing de la cw
le procès des deux libyens accusés de
l'attentât contre le vol panam qui a
explosé au dessus de lockerbie en écosse
a repris aujourd'hui après trois mois
d'interruption
l'attentât avait eu lieu fin 88
entraînant la mort de 270 personnes le
procès se tient dans un ancien camp
militaire au centre des pays bas les
avocats des deux libyens se plaignent de
ne pas avoir assez accès aux documents
notamment ceux de la cia
dans la crise de joe lo les négociateurs
philippins et libyens vous soumettre
cette semaine de nouvelles propositions
aux rebelles du groupe abou sayyaf
roberto havane par ado se rendra
vendredi sans doute à la rencontre des
preneurs d'otages les libye a accepté de
payer un million de dollars pour chacun
des deux otages soit un total de 88
millions de francs
marc tessier président directeur général
de la holding france télévisions pour
les cinq ans qui viennent une holding
désormais plus large qui regroupe la 2
la 3 mais aussi la cinquième et qui a
pour ambition de créer de nouvelles
chaînes et de diffuser via les nouvelles
technologies du numérique hertzien
explications car o'neal aux draps et
raymond chape l'art ils étaient tous là
les neuf membres du ciel ça très
entendre le président de france
télévisions et à lui poser des questions
deux heures et demie d'audition où
furent abordés le bilan des quatorze
mois de son mandat mais aussi l'avenir
de la télévision publique élu à la tête
de la holding pour cinq ans marc tessier
va devoir gérer trois sociétés la 2 la 3
et la cinquième leurs programmes seront
harmonisés et devons offrir une plus
grande diversité culturelle par exemple
la 3 s'intéressera plus particulièrement
aux enfants
la 2 aux adolescents mais le grand pari
sur l'avenir c'est le numérique et
retient à partir de fin 2001-début 2002
sans changer de téléviseur ni d'antenne
avec un simple décodeur 36 chaînes
seront disponibles parmi elles douze
sont accordé à france télévisions on
pourra par exemple accéder gratuitement
à la chaîne infosport aux programmes
régionaux avec la possibilité de se
concocter son propre programme bref le
téléspectateur ne va plus regarder sa
télévision du même oeil
mais il va sûrement changer d'attitude
parce qu'il met plus actifs d'une part
parce qu'il aura évidemment beaucoup de
choix donc il va avoir un choix de plus
en plus exigeants et en plus il pourra
agir
grâce aux services interactifs agir à la
fois dans la recherche de contenus dans
éventuellement participer à des
discussions à des débats poser des
questions et donc effectivement ça
change la façon de consommer la
télévision numérique et retient devrait
concerner 80 % des téléspectateurs
français c'est à dire ceux qui nous sont
abonnés au câble ni aux satellites la
télé numérique c'est pour demain alors à
vos postes
marchetti bonsoir vous avez été nommé ce
matin pour cinq ans président de la
nouvelle holding qui inclut donc la 2 la
3 pouces et la fatiha mais ce que ça
signifie une nouvelle synergie pour le
service public de télévision et bien sûr
non l'objectif est bien et bien et bien
cela d'abord de mieux dépenser l'argent
des téléspectateurs je crois que c'est
très important mais aussi de développer
de nouveaux programmes en commun entre
les trois chaînes je pense que c'est un
beau défi c'est à dire que vous êtes
tous nommés donc cinq ans la durée ça
change quoi ça change de d'avoir des
projets à plus long terme voir les mener
à bien le voir aboutir parfois la durée
ça permet de travailler toutes les
équipes de france télévisions ont besoin
de s'assurer du temps quand on lance un
programme souvent le met à l'antenne
deux ans voire trois ans après quand on
lance une nouvelle chaîne de télévision
comme on va le faire dans le numérique à
tiens qui vient d'être présenté là tout
de suite il faudra au moins des années
aussi pour ceux pour être près
complètement sur tous les sujets donc
cinq ans ça permet de travailler trois
ans c'était vraiment trop court et puis
cinq ans et c'est peut-être un début
vous parlez du numérique hertzien qui on
le sait à toute votre attention combien
de chaînes à terre mais combien de
nouvelles chaînes vont pouvoir être être
créé via le numérique et retient pour le
groupe france télévisions c'est à hilla
pour le groupe public ah non je ne parle
pas des autres et nous avons le projet
de développer 6 nouvelles chaînes donc
de passer au fond de trois plus arte 1
qui est notre consoeur 4 à 10 alors le
gouvernement n'a pas encore pris sa
décision peut-être que il prendra une
décision légèrement différente mais
c'est en tout cas le projet de notre
groupe il va y avoir aussi des
changements sur sur les antennes de
télévision par exemple la durée des
écrans publicitaires va être très vite
réduite absolue mais en même temps le
budget va augmenter aux quelles sont les
priorités pour france 2 à la rentrée
pour d'abord d'abord notre budget
augmente 1 la ministre mt ce qu'a
annoncé aujourd'hui même le nouveau
budget de l'audiovisuel public japonais
votre nomination et je crois je crois
qu'il faut que le service public travail
en toute indépendance mais également
évidemment bonnes relations avec le
gouvernement notamment pour pouvoir
utiliser les fonds publics mais c'est ce
que je voulais dire c'est que nous
sommes depuis deux ans sur une rampe de
lancement très positive après de
nombreuses années je dirais de vaches
maigres enfin le service public commence
à disposer des moyens pour offrir des
programmes de bonne qualité la réduction
des écrans publicité c'est important
pour pour les téléspectateurs il ya
moins de charges mais ça va pas changer
la qualité du contenu non c'est surtout
une décision une décision qui a pour
objet de
d'alléger des programmes de permettre de
passer plus vite d'un programme à un
autre ça répond je crois effectivement
souci de nombreux téléspectateurs la
répartition entre concerne un faux entre
la 2 la 3 ça va rester à peu près les
mêmes orientations ambitieuses non non
nous avons réussi ce tour de force avec
la deux et la trois d'avoir un service
presque continu d'informations ou des
dernières années avec ceux d'autres
projets d'une nouvelle chaîne
d'information ne seront là de l'a3 à la
nouvelle chaîne d'information en
continue au service des téléspectateurs
et comment la 5e va venir s'intégrer
dans l'ensemble de cette de ce périmètre
mais là ça qui m arrive avec ses grands
projets culturels et de connaissances
que connaissent j'espère la plupart des
téléspectateurs elle va travailler en
développant des programmes en commun
avec la deux par exemple des
documentaires des magazines et puis elle
aura je pense sa spécificité ça sera un
peu notre laboratoire d'idées nouvelles
et de format de télévision nouveau et
dernière question marc tessier
concernant la crise de joe lo les otages
français notamment l'équipe de france 2
évidemment être informé vous avez bon
espoir écoutez nous avons toujours bon
espoir on vient de dire que les enfin
des mots des partenaires libyens et
philippins en plus mettre d'accord vous
savez que ce sont ces leur désaccord qui
a fait que samedi notre grand espoir a
été déçu ce que je peux vous dire c'est
que nous avons comme comme nous disons
très souvent contact presque quotidiens
avec notre équipe nous et nous nous
échangeons des lettres ils ont une heure
ils font preuve d'une grandeur d'âme etc
sont extraordinaires je dirais pas
qu'ils ont bon moral je dirais qu'ils
savent exactement où ils vont et pour ça
il nous inspire confiance merci
en football l'allemagne est en finale
dans la coupe intertoto les auxerrois
ont fait match nul face aux allemands de
stuttgart 1 à 1 au match aller les
allemands s'étaient imposés 2 à 0 c'est
donc un résultat plutôt mauvais pour
auxerre
et voilà le deuxième match du tout et on
l'a vu à l'approché des jeux olympiques
ciné se met à la vente de tous les
objets dérivés de ces olympiades déjà
plusieurs boutiques sont ouvertes alors
que les équipes sportives commencent à
arriver sur place reportage de nos
envoyés spéciaux anne morgue et bruno
giraudeau les australiens ne sont pas
que de doux rêveurs ils sont aussi de
redoutables hommes d'affaires
c'est au milieu de la city là où se font
et se défont les fortunes qu'ils ont
implanté la plus grande boutique dédiée
au dieu olympisme ici tout est prévu
pour que les petits souvenirs rapporte
beaucoup d'argent de la gourmette en or
massif au collier à 60 mille francs
l'indispensable chapeau pour affronter
la pluie habituel en septembre sans
oublier les trois incontournables
mascotte
très rarement aux jeux d'atlanta on ne
trouvera ses articles que dans des
magasins spécialisés
certainement pas à tous les coins de rue
ça casse les prix et ça dévalorise nos
produits
une campagne publicitaire à la
télévision cet homme aussi cesser de
vendre les jeux et le pari n'est pas
gagné
un tiers seulement des habitants de
sydney quand y assister
à un mois du début des épreuves il reste
encore deux millions de billets
disponibles
reste des places pour l'athlétisme le
tennis le basket
vous pouvez même assisté à toutes les
phases des compétitions déplacent même
pour les finales il y a un an les
organisateurs affirmé que tout était
vendu aujourd'hui ils reconnaissent leur
erreur et ça ne fait pas très sérieux la
première mise en vente de billets
l'année dernière a été compliquée c'est
vrai on s'est trompé cependant la bonne
nouvelle et pour ceux qui veulent venir
voir les jeux et c'est que le lien comme
ayant vendu 2,5 millions de tickets ce
que reste encore d'autres très bonnes
places disponibles et pour tous les
sceptiques il restera la possibilité de
suivre les jeux à la télévision
c'est la fin de ce journal je vous en
rappelle les deux principaux titres le
président poutine arrive enfin à
mourmansk et déclare une journée de
deuil national
mais certaines familles refusent de
participer à la cérémonie officielle
jean pierre chevènement qualifie d'
insensés les propos de françois santoni
menant sont menaçants de venger lui même
la mort de son ami
dans un instant la météo présentée par
nathalie rihouet à 20h50 un film héroïne
avec virginie ledoyen 00h20 le journal
de la nuit présenté par m était de -
7h50 gérard morin reçoit ségolène royal
ministre déléguée à la famille à
l'enfance trésor antoine cormery et
laurence ostolaza je vous retrouve
demain à 20h très bonne soirée
oh